joining me in the studio now is Florian
Leonard he's from the innovation center
for mobility here in Berlin and thank
you very much for being with us today
all right well PS sound like a great
idea in theory but how realistic are
they are we eventually going to see
highways in this guy I think we will I
think in the next 20 or 30 years we will
at least partially have services of that
kind of operating and I think that
advances in construction engineering
lightweight materials and the design of
these crafts and will allow us to
actually I'm bring them to the market
quite rapidly all right but in just in
terms of safety I mean what are we
looking at we're also talking about you
know noise and accidents what are the
biggest challenges to such an idea well
I think you just summed them up but it's
very much safety the question of how we
actually control air traffic three
dimensionally in a closed organ
environment is essential and probably we
will have to find autonomous flight
automation systems and to do that and
noise is another big issue that is
always sensitive so I think there's some
recessed will still have to go into
fixing that but the other problem is
also issues such as liability and
insurance who is actually to blame when
two autonomous vehicles collage imagine
premiums would definitely skyrocket if
this project came to fruition now you
had a project called intelligent city
which is eventually cities that rely on
only renewable sources of energy so
would moving traffic into the skies fit
into this model and it does we have now
found ways to operate these ultralight
aerial vehicles with electric power and
battery power and hence can charge it
moving noble energy so they would simply
add another component to a renewable
energy system interestingly I'm air a
traffic already has actually a slightly
better passenger mile energy consumption
than the car traffic does and so
particularly in an error in countries
like the United States when I seriously
looking at using aerial mobility system
super place car traffic well and
actually that brings me to my next
question you know the Internet giant
Amazon is definitely looking at this
model but in drones to deliver packages
I'm getting these products to customers
in record time
what are your thoughts on this on this
futuristic project again I think we will
see that becoming reality much faster
than we think particularly with just a
lightweight drone traffic I think it
does also solve a number of problems in
areas where we don't yell have Road so
it's a nice way to deliver things in
environments where there are no roads
building new roads would take up a lot
of more energy as well so I think there
are a lot of applications where drone
delivery can make sense in Amazonas and
the testing this at the moment in San
Francisco okay well um looking back to
look ahead you know just over 100 years
ago Henry Ford introduced a car or
developed a car that was meant to be
affordable and to all the masses now
what can we expect in a hundred years
time when it comes to modes of
transportation I think we can be fairly
certain that the private fossil
automobile will have vanished as a
transportation mode I think we will see
a mix of horizontal and vertical
mobility in cities probably electric
possibly also hydrogen based and that is
clean and that also works are in
mobility on-demand systems rather than a
private vehicle set to use up some space
in our cities all right well we shall
see would perhaps some of these changes
will take place in our time as well
Florian then I thank you very much for
being with us today thank you